I can't believe it either I have a
wonderful electronic invention I want
you to see this probably is the magic
that DJI was gonna be launching next did
you cuz I sure did it but I'm so glad
they did they're calling this an
educational robot this is the DJI Robo
master s1 since 2015 China has been
having this competition it's called the
Robo master competition and I had not
heard of this until vgi announced this
so this is kind of like a smaller
consumer version of what they use in the
competition's I have no idea what I've
gotten myself into with this unboxing
because this is something that is
programmable you also have to put it
together so this thing it comes in a
bunch of different pieces what I love
about it is they're calling it an
educational robot so this isn't
something that just comes in the box
already put together this is something
that you put together that you learn how
it works and using scratch and Python
you can program it you can write
programs on your computer on mobile
tablets on Android on iOS and you can
share them instantly with your friends
or maybe even your not friends because
this thing is made for competitions
so after this unboxing I'm gonna put
this together and then I'm gonna go meet
up with some friends who also have one
yeah okay this is substantial box the
box is actually not very heavy though
which is kind of cool
oh my gosh all the pieces so here's our
instructions and this is the one time
that you will see me place these
delicately off to the side because I
think some think I'm gonna need ok so
this looks like it is probably important
this is like a massive Lego set it's a
lot of pieces
look at this lovely thoughtful little
toolbox that's that's something oh my
this is gonna be really fun you guys are
new here one of the things that I love
so much is I love LEGO sets and I used
to love the Technic sets too cuz you
could actually make things move and
happen I think this is gonna be not
difficult to put together I'm missing
something
oh there's more I should probably does
time lapse myself putting this together
cuz I'm probably gonna be here for a
while
oh look it's all together just kidding
this is the one that they sent that was
already assembled and ready to go it's
crazy how steady this is so it has a two
axis mechanical gimbal and using AI it
can identify other s ones it can
identify people I think eyes are fans of
DJI and their drone line then you know
that their technology and their software
they integrate so well together there's
also one other thing that's not out when
it's launched don't roll off the table
cuz you're not on and you don't know
your name yet there's also these little
water pellets so these soak in water for
about four hours and then they have like
this little chamber you can put these in
and then you load it into the s1 here it
is it's like the size of a Nintendo's
switch okay I gotta start getting this
thing together because I'm running out
of time how am I gonna have time to
learn Python and six hours
we're about to start the installation it
is currently 9:34 p.m. we start now I
think I might have to pick this up
tomorrow because I don't think I'm gonna
get it done tonight because I'm already
tired
I certainly learned to do because I
didn't follow the directions
here's to following the directions a
little bit more closely
let's go
[Music]
oh well I'm actually having a lot of fun
doing this I'm gonna stop now because
I'm getting tired and I'm gonna finish
the rest up tomorrow so I'll be right
back little robot back for Day two
we're finishing this up because tomorrow
or to be taking this out to a warehouse
and I'm going to be playing with a bunch
of my friends who also have this Jana is
also here to help me that's my sister
and I'm going to put the building
instructions on my iPad this is so hard
to see I had to get my glasses
humming elderly now I can't see where
are we at has a personality
this is so freakin cool now that it's
unboxed and all assembled I met up with
some friends who also have one of these
and this is where it's gonna be really
fun you can connect them all to one
router and you can battle each other so
let's battle
we're about to start our battle so let's
meet our contestants
my name is Park aka iphonedo where it
comes from take wander to break stuff
friendly breaking friendly great dancing
I've just seen a king I just need this
is my first time battling that's all
I've got
bulge Anastasio aka like path and this
is gonna be a few things I'm Jenna APA
Jenna here
I just keep typing I got destroyed
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
because I think maybe that was unbelief
we've originally doing a battle mode but
so much stuff was happening so we just
kind of were going into like a
free-for-all mode just kind of trying to
eliminate each other this was unlike
anything I've ever experienced Wow oh my
gosh thousand tents with education well
the best scores the old one yeah except
the ladder
[Music]
[Applause]
you can use the infrared beams or
there's something else but you have
already set up on yours yeah like you
said the infrared beam is a little light
that comes out you can kind of has a
little audio here but if not you can
actually activate the beads which are
really cool it takes about three to four
hours to enlarge the beads they come
like it is really small pellets and
there's just a selection here that you
switch from the infrared to the gel
beads yep then you just have to turn
that a blaster safety on and then you
can now trigger the beads that come out
dumping one of my favorite features of
this thing we've done so many fun videos
together but this one by far I mean
great at the flame forever stuff was
really fun but this was so cool this is
something else one of your favorite
features the ability to program this
because when you program this it helps
you with the artificial intelligence it
was actually tracking me as we were
going and firing off the lasers yes yes
and I wasn't even touching the console
no it was amazing so if you're capable
of programming ballet you have advantage
that's why it becomes more than just a
regular game I think one of my favorite
things though we actually were able to
bring it here and all play together that
was awesome by itself yes it's a lot of
fun but with friends is completely
something else I'm so great this was so
much fun thanks I should be in my video
thank you so much for having me and
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you go check out all of our
channels I will put links in the
description and let's do this again soon
we should we gotta check out this is not
over
tell me more
[Applause]
[Music]